uh good evening and welcome to this
evening's debate it's a great pleasure
to see so many people here this evening
it's probably about three times bigger
than any previous intelligent Square
debate
um and in a very sort of appropriate
setting Methodist Central hall for
tonight's subject
um I'd like to thank very much our
distinguished panel of speakers and also
our moderator this evening Joan Bakewell
for kindly agreeing to participate
um and also a thank you to the Times
newspaper our media sponsor our next
event there's a free event that is
taking place tomorrow night it's not a
intelligent squared style event it's a
question time which we're doing in
conjunction with the National Trust on
never mind the ice caps and and that is
a free event which is going to take
place at the Royal geographical Society
with David miliband Rosie boycott
Professor Phillip Stott after that we
have two more our next debate is prison
works with Lord wolf and after that
democracy isn't for everyone you've
probably seen we've previewed the Autumn
season which is going to and tickets
will be available on sale probably the
end of April first debate is Britain has
failed Zimbabwe so rather hoping nothing
happens to change the change that motion
anyway all it does is to leave me to
thank you all for coming and to pass
over to Joan Bakewell thank you
thank you Zone
[Music]
it's a tribute to the power of ideas and
to the distinguished panel that we have
today that tonight's motion has
attracted so many people to come to hear
the motion that we'd be better off
without religion
it will be conducted like the formal
debates of the Oxford and Cambridge
unions with three speakers on either
side whom we will hear
we will then have the result of the
pre-vote in which you've already cast
your judgment and then we will have
questions and answers before a re-vote
on the motion
fine so let me call upon the person who
is to propose this motion
we would be better off without religion
Christopher Hitchens author journalist
critic
uh writer over here a figure in the
cultural life of this country before he
moved to Washington when he wrote for
Vanity Fair and the nation he started
off on the left wing moved very right
and has recently been dipping the
neocons and
um his latest book which is absolutely
germane to this subject it'll be
published in the coming months and is
called God Is Not Great Christopher
Hitchens
thank you God you'll give me a minute
won't you
thank you very much Joe for that
slightly misleading
introduction to um someone who may no
longer be a socialist but
still vibrates to Marxism uh thank you
ladies and gentlemen for coming I think
I'll be able to be reasonably tersed
given the very heavy artillery
that follows me on our side I think it
might perhaps have been felt when I was
chosen that the case for atheism should
not be made by the spokesman for its
moderate Wing Richard Dawkins
um
it might be okay to have at least one
extremist on the panel
um and I'll begin uh At Once by
recalling an exchange I had recently in
Colorado Springs
with a spokesman of America's
Evangelical broadcasting wing
a much overrated but nonetheless
significant for sin
American politics this is a broadcaster
asked me
in response to my own statement of
unbelief he said I insist that you
answer the following question
and that you answer it with a yes or a
no I braced myself I accepted the
challenge unseen
he said you want to imagine yourself in
a strange city
where you've never been before
you ought to imagine Nightfall coming on
and you to be without friends or sucker
in this town
and you two you want to ask yourself
whether you would feel safer
or less safe
when you saw a dozen men coming towards
you in the dusk
if you were to know that they had
recently come from a prayer meeting
this is the I'm I'm I think I can
justifiably say I'm relaying to you
conrades friends brothers sisters the
challenge that was put by the religious
to me you'll see it once it's not a yes
no answer you can't give a yes no answer
to that but I accept it anyway I said
very well
I won't give a Sesame Street reply but
just without leaving the letter b
I have been in that situation
in Bombay in Belfast in Beirut in
Belgrade in Baghdad and many other
places too and I won't tell you about
all of them but let me just
let me just as it were fill in some of
those latent
blanks
um
in Belfast the capital city of one of
the provinces of this our United Kingdom
as everybody here knows
everything culturally educationally
economically
politically socially has been very
Gravely for at least a quarter
of a century
excuse me at least half a century and
maybe more since partition and before
that this partition is both the outcome
and the cause of sectarian Warfare in
this town by the simple fact that there
are people there who are willing to kill
not just one another but one another's
children
on the basis of what kind of Christian
they are
horrible things are done not just in
pubs and clubs but on the streets on
housing Estates on University campuses
in that City still despite the
relatively good news we've had today
where the situation remains dominated by
barbaric sectarian Party leaders on this
and no other basis uh both churches
demanded their children are sent to
separate schools they each agree with
the other
that Above All Things their own children
must be
protected from the faith of another
faith
uh I don't think I need to elaborate
very much more on uh how horrendous the
consequences of that have been and how
they are enshrined by the way in our own
Constitution which mandates that our own
head of the church
is also the head of the state
and of the Armed Forces
with all the ludicrous Windsor
consequences that you get if you found a
National Church on the family values of
Henry VII
these conditions which are farcical in
England Wales and Scotland are tragic
and ugly
only a few minutes flying time from
where we sit
if I pass on from Belfast to say a
Baghdad where I've recently been
and without reopening any of the
arguments about the rightness or
otherwise of of the Coalition
intervention
in Mesopotamia I think it can be granted
by any fair-minded person that what was
most needed in Iraq after 30 years of
fascism and War
was a period of reflection
a short interlude of calm
during which Iraqis could look about
themselves and decide perhaps whom
they'd like to vote perhaps what kind of
country they'd like to live in what kind
of federal system they might wish to
evolve and to do so unmolested by
violence or Terror the parties of God
have vetoed every hope of that process
the parties of God now have the Iraqi
people in their jaws and they're saying
to them it's not enough
just to kill foreigners or to rail
against Jews or Christians or
secularists that's nothing like enough
uh it's only in Iraq
not only mainly chiefly in Iraq that
it's considered perfectly all right in
fact a religious duty to blow up the
mosques
to destroy the religious schools of
other Muslims of the Muslims of another
school not unlike the pattern of Belfast
it's not enough to have faith you must
have the right version of your own faith
or risk death mutilation and humiliation
and the the destruction
that the inviseration the torture of
Iraqi Society is something that all of
us can read about every day
suppose we're to go to Beirut the pearl
of the Levant the most civilized
and and beautiful and cultured uh city
of the Middle East and to see what
happens
when for for politicized reasons the
sectarian Constitution is in place which
says that the president of Lebanon must
always be a Maronite Christian that the
speaker of its Parliament must always be
a sheer that its vice president must
always be a Sunni that the druze must
have their share and so on leaving out
at the very bottom I'm afraid such
forces as Kurds and Armenians by making
everyone defined in their citizenship by
their faith
do I need to elaborate what that's done
to
to bankrupt to beggar to disfigure and
to degrade
what could have been an ideally plural
and diverse and happy Society
remaining with letter B shall I say
Banya Luca shall I say Belgrade or just
say Bosnia
again one of the most civilized enclaves
of the Balkans
for many years protected by a secular
Constitution under the remains of what
had been the secular and Democratic
Republic and just look what happens
when it is decided that it is that it is
a matter of faith that determines your
citizenship Your Allegiance your
identity your nature your rights see the
recrudescence in the Europe of the late
20th and early 21st century of Catholic
fascist parties we thought we'd left
behind at Nuremberg the eustachia
the recrudescence of forces uh like the
chatniks the Serbian orthodox
uh fascists who took exactly the same
view except the other way around
see the Craven Way in which our
spineless media which always differs to
people of Faith say that it was serbs
who shelled
Sarajevo or croats who shelled monster
when what they should have been saying
was today the Christian Orthodox militia
bombarded an open City around the clock
or yesterday the Catholic forces shelved
mostar From Dawn till Dusk they didn't
do it because it's a matter of taste
we're supposed to respect people of
faith and we're supposed to respect them
while they do that and do that and make
this sort of excuse
uh there are there aren't enough words
in my lexicon at any rate to express the
contempt that I think any right thinking
person must feel for this conscription
of this kind of medieval barbarism
um Joan will tell me when I've got a
minute I don't know how whether I'm yet
trespassing on my um
my rivals and my allies time but um if I
was to add Bombay
to this list the city that was very
nearly ruined by the sectarian partition
of India in 1947 1948 where once again
people were told it's a matter of Faith
what kind of Indian you are you may have
to become a Pakistani if you're Muslim
you have to lose your life on the
proposition you may not just be a Hindu
Bombay more or less survived this the
terrifying ethnic cleansing and the
pogrom that ensued when the subcontinent
was mutilated and maimed and partitioned
on on this basis in the hopes of a
genuine Indian unity and Independence
ruined by way of appeasement of of
people of Faith but Bombay is sort of
recovered until recently when now its
name has been changed
its minority citizens persecuted
intimidated driven out by a new Hindu
nationalist party the shiv Senna that
says that again
if you don't if you do not follow the
right God if you don't accept the
supernatural as a real force in everyday
life you are not worth
uh whatever it takes to become or to
remain or be treated as an ordinary
Democratic civilized human being in
again one of the great cities of Asia
now it's not part of my case and I'm
sure it's not part of Professor
grayling's or Professor Dawkins is
either to say that religion is the
reason for all of this or the exclusive
or sole reason for all of it I think it
would be crude and reductionist to say
that but who is going to argue I'll be
fascinated to see who is going to argue
that the matter of Faith the religious
allegiance that the preachings of
religion have not in all these cases
Gravely exacerbated Gravely deepened
Gravely poisoned and prolonged all of
these things that have made our tenuous
civilization extremely difficult to
defend uphold maintain let alone
to advance I don't believe this case
could be made that's for its simple
reason because religion is not provided
to us by revelation
it doesn't come from the heavens it
doesn't come from the Beyond it doesn't
come from the Divine it's man-made
and it shows
it shows very well that religion is
created invented imposed by a species
half a chromosome away from the
chimpanzee it shows doesn't it
well why do we deceive ourselves on this
point and is there anywhere I'm now
going to wind up
is there anywhere of the places I've
mentioned and I exempt basrath and all
the other bees I could take you around
where it wouldn't be enormously welcomed
if there was a mass conversion to
secularism
or a mass adoption of the secular idea
and principle of the principles of
Bertrand Russell who once spoke famously
from this platform of Thomas Paine of
Thomas Jefferson of Voltaire and and
others and I'll close by saying
that I want you to be on your guard
against two false issues in this respect
and I'll be very brief
when I mentioned those gentlemen
and I could mention some ladies too in
this connection like Mary Wollstonecraft
don't let anyone tell you that oh well
secular tyranny is just as bad after all
they've been fascist and communist
dictatorships which have been just as
revolting fascism as you know was
supported by the Catholic Church all
through its life in a factual after it
had died and still is defended by it one
of the leaders of the axis was actually
the Japanese leader was actually a god
there's no way of saying fascism and
national socialism when the actors was
secular and in the case of stalinism and
maoism in the Khmer Rouge the same
mistake he's made and religion is made
out of man it's the religious impulse
itself that I think we need to oppose to
criticize to criticize in ourselves as
well as in others the argument from
faith in other words the argument from
certainty so those of us who maintain
this may not be described my closing
Point as fundamentalists or secularists
a certain sheep and demagogic and
opportunist forces have recently been
suggesting we do believe in evidence we
do believe in skepticism we do believe
in reason we hold our views we hold our
views with as much conviction and
Principle as any God bothererer does but
we are open to the argument and we're
going to prove it tonight to you and
don't let anyone dare to imply there's a
moral equivalence between us and the
Fanatics and the fools and those who
think they know God's Will and can tell
you what it is who are our enemies and
your enemies too so I beg to propose the
notion that stands in our name thank you
[Music]
thank you
yeah
there's a lot more than that yeah
the motion is opposed by Dr Nigel Spivey
who is a teacher of classical art and
Archeology at Cambridge his books which
are many include songs on bronze Greek
myths retold and he has done several
television series of which one was
called digging for Jesus Dr Spivey
foreign
The Proposal of the motion began by
saying he was putting the case for
atheism and with respect Christopher I'm
going to start by saying this isn't
a debate about the existence of God
it's a debate about us us Mortals The
Crooked Timber of humanity and how the
practice of religion in general affects
us
Karl Marx famously described religion as
an opiate Jonathan Miller thinks it's
more of an amphetamine gets people
overexcited and my own meager religious
experience disposes me to think of it as
a sort of anesthetic by which I mean
that when I am situations of feeling
lonely sad or frightened I find myself
crooning hymns hymns that really relate
to the place where we are they're mostly
Wesleyan hymns but anything really that
has the sentiment of Psalm 23 and the
help Swan whistle and sing through the
valleys of fear and death but
I'm not here to testify as a somewhat
lapsed Methodist
but instead to deliver such academic
expertise as I have to offer on this
topic it's brief has to be brief but in
my view it is so compelling
that when we arrive at the conclusion in
six minutes time
I'm half afraid that everyone will walk
out
and I'd like you to promise not to do
that otherwise this will be an
embarrassment to the organizers and to
ourselves
I'm going to talk about archeology and
anthropology
and start with the news from archeology
the long-term View
as far as that are better as far as we
can tell
the species of homo saplings roamed the
world for thousands of years before
becoming as it were religious something
radical happened in our minds our
cognitive systems about forty thousand
years ago we started to make things for
the sake of beauty not utility we
started painting pictures carving
sculptures we started using symbols and
that probably included talking to to
each other making music painting our
bodies and so on
this is referred to by archaeologists as
the creative explosion and it's a
consensus that there's this kind of
grand Collective takeoff of our human
capacities in the Stone Age or the upper
Paleolithic to be precise
and one aspect here I think I ought to
highlight which is that one of the
features that appears at this time forty
thousand years ago is that humans start
burying each other properly and they
start with these burials to put down
flowers gifts and other signs of what we
take to be some kind of Sucker or
consolation and possibly a belief in an
afterlife there is some debate about
whether our doomed Rivals the
Neanderthals had these sensibilities but
the consensus is that homo sapiens is a
species uniquely hardwired
for metaphysics
I've written about this in an
understated book called How Art made the
world and I'm not going to go on any
more about it but this archaeological
evidence for the Genesis of art religion
and culture in the creative development
of homo sapiens is not easily discounted
and it sets up an evolutionary pattern
it explains why I think when John Lennon
or Richard Dawkins asks us to imagine a
world without religion
you find your mind wandering and you're
wondering what a world would look like
without King's College Chapel without
the Taj Mahal without Haya Sofia the
Blue Mosque the Parthenon the pantheon
the Sistine Chapel
Venice I've got down here I think just
about all of Venice qualifiers
and you become aware that even while
Nietzsche in the 1880s was declaring
that God was dead at the same time
you've got Van Gogh manically daubing
away out of religious fervor and a
little later on that you find Kandinsky
more coolly explaining why this Nexus of
art music and spirituality
uh made such an essential and
indissoluble Alliance for our quest for
transcendental satisfaction
and it's why when I master imagine a
world without religion it does tend to
end up looking like
dare I say that a suburb of Swindon with
the only the only Spire the only Spire
that pierces the sky is the Tesco's
clock
well we've got a few minutes for the
anthropology
um here as well
once upon a time there was a Classics
Don at Cambridge who sat in his study
and he compiled a voluminous series of
case studies gathered from around the
colonized World about how pre-industrial
societies kept up peculiar and primitive
practices
so they cowered when the Thunder started
rolling they danced for rain they would
copulate in the fields to ensure a good
harvest and so on
it's a literary Masterpiece this worked
by J.G Fraser the golden bow
subtitled a study in Magic and religion
and in Fraser's words it's set out to
chart the Long March the slow and
toilsome Ascent of humanity from
savagery to civilization
beautifully written
but it's all Tosh and most
anthropologists would say so today
in fact it was not an anthropologist but
another Cambridge individual Ludwig
Wittgenstein
who made some remarks offhand as it
seems about Fraser's golden bow and
pointed out that Fraser's method was
fundamentally fundamentally mistaken he
supposed Fraser supposed that Savages
these so-called Savages made their
sacrifice to Graven Idols or they danced
for rain out of ignorance and
superstition
but as wittenstein argued the essence of
ritual is performance it's expressive
it's something that you can't gloss with
a reasonable explanation in
wittgenstein's word we can only describe
and say human life is like this
um have I got time for an analogy one
minute probably not time for the
marriage I was going to tell you about
the risks of attempting to react
violently to a computer when it does
something stupid which is based on the
analogy that Wittgenstein gives of
hitting the ground when you're angry
it's not because you think you're going
to hurt the ground it's because you want
a release of Rage I will just briefly
incidentally say that it is a very bad
idea to hit a laptop
William James the American psychologist
showed a century ago that there is no
logical connection to be made between
the fact that our ancient ancestors made
errors of scientific reasoning mix them
up with their religion
and the conclusion that all religion is
a big mistake logically that just does
not work
if I had another hour here I'd like to
expatiate on the extraordinary
phenomenon of how one religion overlaps
with another and how especially the
Persistence of sacred behavior from the
pagans of the classical world is
something you know the yew trees and the
churches the roots of the cult of the
virgin in Antiquity and so on
but I'm going to end up by saying that
around the world whatever we say here
tonight around the world the Sea of
Faith rolls on
it rolls on because faith is not some
kind of atavistic relapse but part of
our creative and ingenious nature it's a
force by which we humans survive and the
conclusion is that this fact is attested
archaeologically
anthropologically psychologically and I
dare say neurologically
and the conclusion would be that for the
next hour or so
can I tell you this in a sense we are
wasting our time debating that we'd be
better off without religion it's not an
option
religion is part of our human makeup and
it's going to be a very interesting uh
time that we spend but essentially it's
not a topic for debate
it's the way that we are
brilliant well done
seconding the motion is Professor
Richard Dawkins whose many books I'm
sure you are familiar with the selfish
Gene
started in 1976 and there was a torrent
of books that followed with wonderful
titles like the blind watchmaker River
out of Eden unweaving the rainbow
his present book has no such romantic
title
it has a very strong punch to it The God
Delusion was published late last year
and was quickly a bestseller and has
caused something of a sensation so I
call upon Professor Richard Dawkins to
second the motion
find it
I do not believe that religion is the
root of all evil
thank you Channel 4.
religion is the root of quite a lot of
evil
that that didn't make for a very catchy
title
I just want to briefly reply to Dr
Spivey a couple of points he says we're
fighting a losing battle because
religion is a part of our human nature
well speak for yourself
it's not a part of mine and it's not a
part of the Great majority of my friends
in universities uh in England and the
United States and elsewhere
he also said if we had no religion
how would we do without King's College
Chapel the Sistine Chapel Etc
well you know artists have to make a
living
and in the time when the Sistine Chapel
was built and its ceiling was painted
you know who had the money
artists such as Michelangelo had to go
where the patronage was we shall never
know the ceiling that Michelangelo might
have painted if he had been commissioned
to paint
um the Museum of Science for example we
shall never know what Haydn's Evolution
oratorial might have sounded like
or Beethoven's Mesozoic Symphony
now I suppose that apologists for
religion would be likely to put forward
for
reasons for believing it to be a good
thing four things that religion does for
us and I call them explanation
exhortation exhortation meaning morals
explanation meaning explaining the world
where we come from where the universe
comes from its own exhortation what is
good what is bad
inspiration
and consolation
and I think
my colleague Anthony Grayling is likely
to cover some aspects of exhortation I
shall be brief on that therefore
um
consolation
I often encounter people who say but if
you take religion away from people
how are they going to survive how are
they going to manage when they're
bereaved or when they when they lose a
loved one when they fear death
themselves
and it's a it's a reasonable Point uh it
is certainly possible to obtain
constellation
from a lie
many people
will say if you ask them would you like
your doctor to tell you when you have a
mortal illness and you're only going to
live another six months there are people
who will say no I would rather my doctor
lied to me
and that's fine and I would respect that
wish if I were a doctor if I thought
that a patient wanted to be lied to but
I don't think it's a very dignified
General reason for supporting religion
that it supplies consolation unless of
course it's true and that we haven't
time to go into it but I think there are
very very good reasons for thinking that
there is absolutely no grounds for
believing that there's any actual truth
in the claims of religion
so those who get who gain consolation
from religion I must confess that I
rather liken it to a child with a with a
dummy in its mouth
um I don't think it's a very dignified
or very respect worthy posture for an
adult to go around uh sucking a dummy
with a with a comforter which is what I
think it essentially is
inspiration
well
I've always found the inspiration uh the
the heavens declare the glory of God all
things bright and beautiful and so on to
be poultry parochial
small-minded compared to the inspiration
that you can get by looking at the world
of science
deep space deep time
as the late Carl Sagan showed us
deep complexity in the study of life
the scientific study of these profound
beautiful elegant
Mysteries
is one of the greatest achievements of
the human spirit
and insofar as religion offers an
alternative or even positively stands in
the way of scientific
activity then I think we would be well
rid of it
which brings me to the other of my four
categories explanation
in the field of explanation science has
all the cards religion used to Aspire to
a reasonably good hand but no longer
there is no reason to suppose that any
religion any religious book any
religious teacher has anything to say
whatsoever
about such questions as where the
universe comes from what life is all
about what life is for any of those
questions which Once Upon a Time
religion provided the the best available
answers
these are now completely washed up
there is no evidence for them at all
and it's worse than that because the
point I want to end up with is that
science sorry is that religion
debauches education
in so far and it's quite a long way in
so far as it uh
interferes with the education of
children and students it's not just the
teaching of falsehoods it is that the
indoctrination of children in the
virtues of faith
leads them to be immunized to be placed
on their guard
against the enemies of Faith who they
are told will come it's as though it's
rather like a computer erecting a
firewall
to prevent incoming information
I have talked to colleagues in America
scientists attempting to lecture to
students on their subject biology and of
course biology makes no sense without
Evolution and whenever a lecturer
mentions Evolution he sees a great sea
of heads shaking arms folded and they
are not listening they are trained to
give the right answers they're trained
to tick the right boxes when they do the
exam they know how to answer an exam on
Evolution but they have been forewarned
forearmed by the firewall of Faith
whenever a teacher says anything about
evolution in effect stop up your ears
now that is debauching of Education
a quote from
Kurt wise
who is an American geologist he studied
geology at Harvard no less under Stephen
J Gould no less
and he was set for a good career as an
academic geologist which all his life he
had desperately wanted the problem was
it came from within it was his religious
upbringing his firewall of faith
and he couldn't reconcile the two his
scientific education with his religion
and he literally got a pair of scissors
and went right through the Bible and cut
out every verse that would have to go if
he accepted his scientific education
and in the end he decided there was
nothing left of his Bible he therefore
tossed out science
and said and from then on he said um
with that in great sorrow I tossed into
the fire all my dreams and hopes in
science and he goes on
I am a young age creationist because
that is my understanding of the
scripture as I shared with my professors
years ago when I was in college if all
the evidence in the universe turns
against creationism I would be the first
to admit it but I would still be a
creationist because that is what the
word of God seems to indicate here I
must stand
if religion can do that to a highly
educated Harvard geologist just think
what it can do to an average school
child or student
thank you
our next speaker against the motion is
Rabbi Julia neuberger who was Rabbi of
the South London liberal synagogue she's
also written many books of which the
most recent is called the moral State
we're in Julia noiverger
well ladies and gentlemen I'm delighted
to be here and thank you all very much
for coming and I'm rather wondering what
connection Roger scrutin is going to
find with Methodist Central Hall after
Nigel Spivey as I as a child as a member
of the West London synagogue used to
come to overflow services for the high
holy days here and for those who know
about the Yom Kippur the day of
atonement a fast day for 25 hours can
you imagine this Hall as full as it is
now with us all fasting and the scent of
fish and chips slowly wafting up through
the floor so I have strong memories of
my father conducting the services as a
lay reader and being here but perhaps
that's not quite the meat of tonight's
motion I'm about as liberal a rabbi as
you can be without falling off the edge
nevertheless
I'm profoundly opposed to this motion
first
let's look at how religion is described
for the perception of religion that
we've heard is simply one I largely
don't recognize it doesn't seem to
recognize or understand the role of
religion in many societies where the
question of belief takes second place to
how you mark your life events
how you're celebrated at Birth and at
maturation how you mark marriage
childbirth old age and death how we
mourn how we betrothed and how we
divorce
how do you ask the members of my old
congregation where I where I was Rabbi
for 12 years in South London whether
they believed in a personal God and if
so what the nature of that God was
they'd have looked completely rounded at
you
many of them weren't Believers as it
appears the opposition here or perhaps I
should say the proposition understands
it
they simply didn't feel like that they
weren't certain for them the idea that
you would have creationism taught in
schools would be simply appalling
unlike people who are confirmed atheists
however they had doubt they had
uncertainty
at some point in their lives they had a
sense of the other of a different
Superior presence within and Beyond them
and on other days their doubts were
stronger
but they behaved as if they held a
stronger belief they prayed sometimes
with true humility and party and
sometimes out of habit by rote a bit
like Nigel Psalm 23 which is very
comforting in times of trouble
they lived their lives according to the
seasons of the religious festivals
celebrating Passover with its message of
Liberation From Slavery each year
recognizing its moral message but more
or less certain as to whether it was
divine intervention that caused
Liberation at all
they marked the day of atonement asking
forgiveness for their sins some years
more some years less conscious of a
Divine being that would listen to them
at best they use this as a day to
reflect and the season beforehand to
make peace with those they had offended
in the previous year
at worst it was a ritual recycle of a
recognition that we all do wrong and
that there's some value in a day of
reflection on how we behave and a form
of what I can only describe a spiritual
spring cleaning
I make the point to show that not all
religion is theologically consistent
indeed when the greatest Jewish scholar
of the 20th century Rabbi Dr Louis
Jacobs I love her Shalom was asked to
write a book on Jewish theology for the
Catholic Publishers Dalton Longman and
Todd he insisted that they called it a
Jewish theology because Jews have so
many different views and so many
different opinions
the old joke two Jews three opinions
isn't in fact a joke but it's a
statement of fact
belief matters a good deal less than how
you live your life indeed the test of
the good Jew is what you do and how you
behave and not really at all about what
you believe
so one reason I feel so strongly that we
wouldn't we wouldn't be better off
without religion is that by no means all
religion is fundamentalist extreme
exclusive and damaging at its best it's
something modest inspiring and
sustaining
the modern division to my mind should be
seen as that between those full of
certainty who Scorn the beliefs of
others and have a dogma of their own
that allows no real debate and those who
are occasionally full of Doubt but who
are tolerant and who are respectable
respectful of other people's views that
division is by no means between the
religious and the secular the Crusades
Islamic Jewish and Christian
fundamentalism fascism and communism are
all the results of total certainty
for me the moderates religious or not
are the ones who need to unite and those
moderates within the religious world
have much to give to teach and yes also
to learn
I've lived and worked within modern
non-orthodox Enlightenment influenced
religious communities most of my adult
life
communities For Whom the idea that
Revelation is a once and forever event
is complete anathema
but for whom the idea that we are put
into this world with a purpose however
dimly we may perceive it is a given
with all the passionate rationalism
rationalism the convinced atheists bring
to bear they miss the experiential what
motivates so many people to do good
it is that sense that we are here for a
purpose to make the world a better place
that has led so many to social reform
that wouldn't otherwise have taken place
it was for instance
we'll have the questions later Kristen
you'll get your turn
it was for instance religious
sensibility that brought us hospice and
palliative care
you may or may not share the convictions
of those who developed it but you could
hardly deny that in terms of Modern
Health Care the relief of pain of people
who are dying has been one of the great
advances one that many really good
scientists desperate to find cures
simply didn't consider a consider
we'll take another example that of
slavery the slave trade in its abolition
the bicentenna of which we're marking
this week
plenty of religious people were involved
in the slave trade and plenty of
prettier religious people too
but it was the strong religious
sensibilities of Wilberforce and his
colleagues largely but not wholly Quaker
and non-conformist Christians that
brought an end to the slave trade in
Britain
not soon enough
not humanly aware enough
but as a result of religious thinking
from the Puritan tradition on often
profoundly influenced by that Old
Testament God that so many people so
deride but they preached they persuaded
they campaigned they demonstrated and
they finally got the change through
we'll take a more recent example the
make poverty history Campaign which had
a mixture of people of all ages races
religions communities present in
Edinburgh nearly two years ago and that
has certainly influenced British
politicians to give more Aid
on those platforms speaking to crowds of
whom many were motivated by their
religious feelings that were imams and
Cardinals rock singers and politicians
people of faith and none gathered
together inspired by a Cause
the voices of the Hebrew prophets were
powerful in the words of the speakers
religious or not and Isaiah struck a
chord amongst people opposed to
religious force and form but passionate
about doing the right thing
I'm running out of time but I want to
make one last point
and that's about humility
and the religious experience of living
ordinary faithful lives
working as a communal Rabbi I saw
ordinary people trying to live good
Lives who wanted and want to do the best
they can in an imperfect world to even
our inequalities where they could and to
if you like try and campaign for social
justice
they recognize an obligation to give 10
of their income away to charity each
year
some of them cared for profoundly
disabled people either at home as carers
or professionally giving service because
of their sense of purpose
anything but arrogant they were bound
together by a sense of Duty to family
community and The Wider World they were
and are profoundly good people looking
for honest Ways to Live honest decent
lives in my view
if we didn't have religion would be even
more selfish self-indulgent certain and
cruel more than we already are religious
people can without doubt be all those
things but they can at best change the
world because they believe in moral
purpose experience a sense of
inspiration above and beyond themselves
as many of us do and inspired by their
belief to act thank you
thank you
the third speaker for the motion
first Speaker for the motion is
Professor Anthony Grayling professor of
philosophy at birkbeck College author of
many books about philosophy Berkeley
Wittgenstein Russell biography of Hazard
who also wrote a book called what is
good the search for the best way to live
appropriately and his new book is called
against all gods Professor grayling
foreign
gets up to speak this late in the debate
one's a bit tempted to quote that
Hungarian MP who after a long long
discussion in the parliament of Budapest
stood up and said everything has been
said but not everybody said it yet
some of you might have noticed the news
item today about
um the pope Pope Benedict XVI giving a
sermon last weekend in Rome and telling
the congregation reminding them perhaps
that hell is a real place it's a a
palpable tangible place and the Eternal
fires of Hell really exist and those who
don't accept Jesus he said I'm
paraphrasing here will will roast
eternally but because of their failure
to do so and this shows um how very
up-to-date uh Pope Benedict is because
obviously he's heard about tonight's
debate and this is an intervention
although I've been trying to work out
all day on week side it's an
intervention and is he trying to
persuade you to vote you know against
the motion or is he actually a fifth
columnist on our side of the argument
well it isn't clear now I imagine a
martian PhD student I suppose there are
also PhD students from Venus as well but
this is a Martin PhD student who is
studying the ethical systems on planet
Earth and has read all the documents all
the Treatise all the philosophical works
the scriptures the teachings of the Holy
fathers and has come to the point in
which he's got to do some field work and
so he is beamed down by the Martian
equivalent of of Scotty to Waterloo
Station at Russia so there are plenty of
people about and he falls into the
conversation with people having coffee
waiting for their trains and he asks
them a question actually rather an
astute question he doesn't ask them what
they think is right and wrong good or
bad and why instead he asks them this he
says what kind of people would you like
your children to be when they grow up
they asked them this because he wants to
get from them to elicit from them their
very best thoughts about the best kind
of life and so he knows that he's going
to catch them in a sober and
well-judging frame of mind when they
think seriously about what kind of
people they'd like their children to
become
and he finds when he's talked to enough
such people that there's quite a
consensus among them they say things
like this I I'd like my children to be
responsible people I like them to take
responsibility for themselves get an
education get a good job and I can have
a family and friendships deep
friendships because they're so valuable
and enriching and with their families
well I'd like them to care for their
children tenderly and carefully and I'd
like them to bring up their children to
think for themselves and to take
responsibility for themselves I wouldn't
want my children to be just always
submitting to the authority of I don't
know a politician or a a teacher or you
know I'd like them to be inquisitive and
to inquire and to think for themselves
and then the Martian PhD student system
is absolutely extraordinary which um all
you people say these things about what
you want for your children because this
is nominally a Christian country isn't
it I mean and isn't it the case that uh
even if you no longer actually believe
the teenage of the of the Christian
faith you were sort of in the position
of the young man from Moldavia you
remember that that little poem there was
a young man from Moldavia couldn't
believe in the Savior so he erected
instead with himself as the head the
religion of decorous behavior and this
was meant to be you know deduced or
inferred at any rate from the from the
basis of Christian morality but there's
nominantly Christian country says our
Martian how can it be that you said what
you said it's a strong astonishing
because in the New Testament you are
taught to take no thought for the mara
consider the lilies of the field don't
have a a pension don't put money aside
don't educate your children and help
them to prepare for a future take no
thought for the Mario the Lilies of the
Field don't and yet you are not arrayed
as these also give away all your money
give it away to the poor and follow me
then you're going to if you have
possessions it's going to be very very
difficult for you to get into heaven the
eye of the needle well we know how
that's been glossed in the centuries
since but it just says it's more
difficult for a rich person comfortably
off person get into heaven and to pass
through the uh and then for a camel to
pass it I have a needle in other words
the the the teaching of the of the New
Testament ethics which I would submit to
you is not bad as teachings of Ethics go
it doesn't really compare to the great
systems of Aristotle lettuce or the
stoics or of Buddhism Buddhism Terror of
arborism is not a religion it doesn't
have any supernatural beings in it it's
a philosophy uh or of the moral Outlook
of the Enlightenment or of some of the
thinking about the good life the
well-lived decent and responsible life
today none of which appeal to the
existence of Supernatural agencies as
the source of a Divine command
all right it's not it doesn't it the
Christian ethical Outlook is is one of
the better of those and yet when you
look at it and you you see what it
demands of you it is very contrary to
the way we think of a decent life now
and moreover it says Imagine The Martian
PhD hearing from his interlocutors on
Waterloo Station that they want their
children to be happy
says the Martian PhD student I mean it
says blessed are they who weep and more
I mean don't you want them to be
miserable so they can get into the
Afterlife I mean it looks as though
there's such a radical inconsistency
between that one of the better religious
ethical outlooks and what it is you want
from your children that it's very hard
to to know what to think about it
because after all says the margin I've
been reading all the documents and uh as
a result of reading them I was I said to
Scotty that chapter beating me down from
Mars I said look be very careful weren't
you about where I end up both time and
place so I don't want to end up in um
Israel at the time of Moses just in case
they mistake me for a midianite or an
amalekite or any of the others who are
massing it please don't make sure I
don't end up in Spain in the late 15th
century with tokamada or in kelvin's
Geneva at the time he was burning
Michael savitas or in zwingli's Zurich
when he was drowning the anabaptists or
please not in today's Baghdad Bombay by
Beirut even Belfast for that matter make
sure you get me to Waterloo Station in
2007.
because when I when I'm not thinking
about uh the best the better of the
religious moralities uh in the Christian
New Testament
um gosh really uh you I I think about
all these other teachings I find that it
is not simply a question of the
teachings being very questionable
not just the question of the practice
allegedly based on those teachings which
is very questionable but the entire
assumption the entire Outlook about what
it is to be a good person and to live a
good and decent life which is so at odds
with the way we in our secularized
modern Western liberal democracies have
come to see as life of achieving it and
flourishing and doing well for others
and I end on this on this one note
um Julia pointed out that uh and so
indeed did Nigel that religion and its
Inspirations and the artists produced
and the rest played a very important
part in what you might call and what I
might just speaking securely called the
spiritual aspect of our lives our
emotional and intellectual responses our
enjoyment of beauty our desire for love
and I I mentioned this to you as a hitch
in his eloquent intervention during that
moment was implying
those who don't have a religious Outlook
appreciate a fact about human beings but
for all their capacity for greed and
unkindness and cruelty and the rest they
also have a remarkable capacity for the
good
a deep sense of connectedness with other
people and a desire to be connected with
the world as a whole you look at people
in their Gardens or going for a walk in
the country or at a concert or looking
at pictures in an art gallery and you
see that you don't need Supernatural
agencies or religions or ancient
scriptures to explain the fact that
human beings are capable of good and
that most of the good that there is in
the world has come from that source and
not from some alleged Supernatural
Source any thanks
our final speaker against the motion
more of that later our final speaker
against the motion is another
philosopher uh he is Roger scrutin who
has written many books upon his subject
he's written about uh Aesthetics he's
written about music philosophy of
architecture and he's written a book
called philosophy principles and
problems into which perhaps this motion
fits so please welcome Roger's group
foreign
thank you very much and chairman and
thank you everybody for being here for
this extraordinary debate uh Rabbi
Julian neuberger
asked um or suggested I might say
something about my own connection with
Methodist Hall
what I can say is that my father
when it crossed his mind that perhaps he
should not bring his children up
entirely without religion
searched our local Town High Wycombe for
the gloomiest chapel he could find it
was the Methodist
and we were duly sent there each Sunday
he not of course attending being a uh
we're hoping to Hope keep hold of the
remaining bits of cheerfulness in his
already gloomy personality
and this had a very remarkable effect on
me it meant that I secretly went every
Sunday not to the Methodist Chapel but
to the Anglican Church
uh uh and also to Confirmation lessons
thereafter not unconnected with the
presence at those lessons of a very
attractive girl in a white Macintosh
this was my first encounter with um that
aspect of the religious experience which
some people call transcendental and I
I have held on to it ever since and I
entirely agree with our first Speaker Dr
Spivey that this is something that will
never be removed from The Human
Condition
now I I have to speak as a philosopher
so I refer to one of the great
philosophers Plato who set out to
describe an ideal Republic in which
reason would Prevail over passion and in
which the citizens would be guided by
the truth
it is fair to say that Plato found
ordinary Humanity to be a profound
disappointment as do most of the
speakers on the other side
in all kinds of ways people conspired
against their own happiness by allowing
the darker forces within to gain the
upper hand they amused themselves with
poetry which told them lies about the
heroes and gods in politics they
preferred consoling lies to
uncomfortable truths and so tied
themselves in knots of self-deception
when it came to music they had a
distressing tendency to prefer the
orgastic tunes and rhythms of the pop
stars
instead of the the upright marches which
bring order to the soul
all in all human beings as they existed
in Plato's day were on the side of
disorder falsehood and irrationality the
only solution was to devise a new kind
of society with the philosophers in
charge and the forces of unreason
expelled into the outer Darkness
The Poets would be ordered to leave so
too with the priests of Dionysus and
other orgiastic Cults so too would the
korabans and the pop stars people would
be educated on a diet of pure philosophy
which would ensure that reason prevailed
in every decision and that the soul of
the citizen would be as well ordered and
harmonious as the soul of the state
Plato was only one of the many thinkers
down the ages who have advocated an
ideal of reason and reasonableness and
who have dismissed those aspects of The
Human Condition which fail to conform to
it
Plato was ambivalent about religion
since he believed that it had both
rational and irrational forms but he was
adamant that the irrational forms were
dangerous and that we we would be better
off without him without them
suppose someone were to say that we
would be better off without love
after all love often leads to disaster
the love of Helen for Paris for instance
which led to the Trojan War love brings
with it jealousy possessiveness
Obsession and grief
people can love the wrong things and the
wrong people they can go astray through
love as they do through hatred
most people in this room I hope would
respond to that argument in the
following way they would say whatever
the disasters that love may cause love
judging itself and without regard to
contingencies is a human good
perhaps the greatest of human Goods the
important thing is to learn to love
rightly and in the right frame of mind
the disasters if they come come as
accidents and not by necessity
that is surely that the response that
should be made on behalf of religion
of course religion leads to disasters
like the 30 years look War people can
believe in false gods attach themselves
to evil rituals and so on Regional can
have exert a stultifying effect on the
intelligence imagination and Humanity of
those who subscribe to it
do we think that that is not true also
science sometimes
anyway none of those possibilities
implies that there is not a proper
development of the religious urge in
which people learn to worship the right
things in the right way
Christopher Hitchens travels around the
world looking visiting places beginning
with the word with the letter b and
discovering all around him insoluble
conflicts
maybe that's partly his problem but I of
course those problems those conflicts
exist
but is religion the cause of them or
just one of the ways in which they are
expressed visiting one of those places
beginning with the letter B once namely
Beirut in the middle of the Civil War I
went out of the city to a nunnery nearby
in the countryside nearby in which all
kinds of victims of the Civil War have
been had found refuge and were being
looked after by a little nun
and I said to her how on Earth can you
cope with this influx of damaged people
what are you to do about it and she said
to me for something very simple she said
he born
she opened her arms and said he gives us
back
10 times what we offer him and what has
he offered her he'd offered her the
ability to look after damaged people of
every faith and restore them to a sense
of normality and to live life again that
seemed to me to be an adequate
expression of the religious urge
defend the religious urge we have to
know what kind of thing we as religious
people are and this is the place where
philosophy has something to say what
part of our nature draws us to religion
and what is needed if that part is to be
rightly guided
science and logic are not the only
spheres in which our reason shows itself
we seek for the causes of things but we
also seek for their meaning we have
moral values aesthetic tastes yearnings
and aspirations which for want of a
better word we call spiritual
such things are not irrational even if
we find it difficult to provide a
scientific foundation for them indeed it
is only a rational being who experiences
the world in this way in terms of
meanings values tastes and aspirations
and who feels as a result the tension
between his life and his ideals there is
nothing irrational in this on the
contrary not to fear it is to be only
half alive to The Human Condition it is
what I suspect Christopher Hitchens felt
seeing the disasters which he
encountered as a journalist
people who do not convey to us since
whatever way an awareness of their
shortcomings do not attract our sympathy
they're not really of Our Kind
and isn't it plausible to think that it
is precisely this aspirational side of
people that draws them to religion as
rational beings we cannot be satisfied
with causal explanations only the
question why has for us another meaning
not what is the cause but what is the
reason
for what end does this or that exist Dr
Professor Dawkins religion has nothing
to say about what life is for so he said
to us but in fact it's precisely
religion which addresses the question
what life is for as opposed to what
caused it as rational beings we look for
meanings connections harmonies and
symmetries we want the world to make
sense to us and to answer our questions
not merely in the sense in the way the
laws of nature answer the inquiries of a
scientist but in the way that the laws
of Harmony answer the aspirations of a
musician
our reason overreaches the bounds of
Science and this is not a deficiency in
our reason but a deficiency in science
moreover as rational beings we make an
absolute distinction between right and
wrong good and evil virtue and vice and
we found our lives on the belief that
some things are intrinsically worthwhile
and to be pursued for their own sake not
pleasure only but love Duty virtue and
kindness we can't mount a deductive or
scientific argument in favor of those
values for all that Professor Grayling
says but we condemn those who condemn
them and believe that reason is on our
side
all those facts about the human
condition dispose us to look for the
places where we can stand as it were at
the window of our empirical world and
gaze out towards the transcendental the
places from which light from that other
sphere floods over us as it flooded over
that little nun in the nunnery in near
Beirut
there is nothing irrational in looking
for these places or in the thought that
we find them by locating what is sacred
sacred words sacred texts and sacred
rituals
now I don't deny that there are wrong
ways of pursuing this religious Quest
those for whom faith is a call to arms
are obviously a threat to all of us but
although they make the most noise they
are not the most numerous among
religious people for most people
religion is what it has always been a
cultivation of piety a humility in the
face of creation and an attempt to live
according to a shared moral code
that is what reason demands and it is
only those who have a narrow and
stultifying view of human reason who
wish to reduce it like Plato to the
abstract pursuit of philosophy in order
to reduce it still further like
Professor Dawkins to the more concrete
pursuit of science who would wish to
banish religion from our ideal Republic
it is only such people who are in my
view the enemies of Reason who could
imagine that this constant companion of
our species which has been at our side
through all our sorrows and all our Joys
is somehow Superfluous to our real
requirements and can be kicked out of
the city Gates along with all the art
and poetry and music that makes no sense
without it and all the aspirations and
ideals that in plants in the ordinary
human soul
thank you
now the subject is now Up For Debate but
before we begin I will give you the
result of the pre-vote which is uh which
you voted for as you came in and on the
motion we'd be better off without
religion those there were 826 votes for
681 against which is a majority for the
motion of 145 but there were
364 don't knows so there is this is time
to make up your mind
um there are microphones in each of the
different areas and I'm happy to take
questions and put them to the different
people it on the platform there's one
conspicuously here at the moment but I'd
like to take several at once let's start
with that one
take a microphone over there too for me
please yes hi uh could I ask
um Professor Grayling Dawkins and
Christopher Hitchens if uh they are
strict materialists or physicalists by
which I mean that
um absolutely nothing exists
except the physical Universe
um
or if they're willing to allow for the
possibility of a further reality or
indeed realities other than the physical
Universe right who will take that
question
I'm the least qualified so perhaps I'd
be the one
um Richard can you hear me
but I thought I had a microphone can you
hear him now the microphone's on yes
is it on or not
yeah as the least qualified I think I
could probably be the most brief um I
don't believe anyone on the other side
can tell me that there's a non-mature
universe
it's a matter of Occam's razor really
ladies and gentlemen uh those who say
they know that there's a God which is
what a religious person must believe
they can't say it's optional they can't
say it's another name for human rights
or charity they must say they do believe
there is something Supernatural that
provides Faith they can't get out of it
like like the rabbi tried to by
confusing it with good works they must
they must also say if they're religious
but God knows what we should do
uh what we should eat with whom we
should have sex in what positions and so
forth
if they don't say that they're not
religious I'm very sorry now I think
it's very easy to tell right away I may
not know in fact I don't believe with my
cranial capacity even Professor
dawkins's cranial capacity it's possible
to know what's happening with dark
material we may never be able to know
but don't put your trust in anyone who
says that they do those people are
eliminated from the argument right away
they cannot be right they have been
practicing an imposture on the human
species for centuries for Millennia we
happen to live in the lucky period where
their claims have been found to be false
or Superfluous or super irrogatory there
is therefore no other way in which you
can decide your virginite professor
Dawkins
uh
I would just add to that that these the
science of any uh one century is going
to be superseded by the science of
future centuries such that if somebody
from say the Middle Ages were to come
would be brought back by a time machine
to now they would find mobile phones and
and uh computers and and jet airplanes
they would be indistinguishable from
Magic they would appear to be
Supernatural so I am a materialist I
don't believe there is anything
Supernatural
but don't think of that as a denigration
of the natural because if you were to
come back in 500 years time
you wouldn't have seen nothing yet
the the physics the engineering the
biology of 500 years time will be so far
Advanced over today's that we might well
fall on our knees and worship it as
Supernatural but it wouldn't be it would
be the evolved uh natural Anthony do you
want to add to that yes just very
quickly I second uh both those sets of
remarks of course I just want to add
though that um thinking that there is
just the natural world governed by
natural laws and that there aren't
Supernatural entities or agencies in the
universe still less any that have any
direct interest in as hitch says what we
wear and what we eat and when and so on
in thinking that one mustn't again fall
into another trap which is to think that
um somehow your attitude to the natural
world is one of um so-called
fundamentalist certainty and the great
thing about the scientific mindset is
its acceptance of open texture of the
fact there are lots of things we don't
know and understand and we're looking
for and trying to understand and we're
prepared not to LEAP to closure to LEAP
to a neat easy story to understand which
tells us what the beginning was and what
the end is going to be very often in the
case of people who appeal to religions
to provide that kind of explanation what
they're doing is that they're answering
the question why is there a World by
saying well because Fred made it as if
that answered anything substitute God
for Fred there by the way or you know
what why are we here because Fred wants
us to be it you haven't answered
anything if you give a supernaturalistic
answer to it but the fact that there are
lots of unanswered questions in science
it's just the fact about this
preparedness the intellectual courage to
go on not knowing all the answers but
looking for them as actually Professor
Sydney Morgan Russell said when asked
the question why is there something
rather than nothing said if there was
nothing you'd still be complaining right
I'm going to wrap up several questions
together now otherwise people when
there's somebody over there there's
somebody here and there's someone up
there so can we hear those three
questions please yes
I want to question ask a question and I
think many of us think about when we're
parents
I want to ask
um baroness Julia new neuberger about
our children what are they going to
believe my children I have three one's a
doctor but they don't go to
church or to
synagogue or to any religious ceremony
what will happen to them and their
children what will their children
believe could you give me some
indication please of what to predict
what is going to happen to religion in
the future thank you very much we'll
hold over that question Julius and made
a note of it I'm sure yes
Madam chairman
um Christopher Hitchens seems to imply
that unless one practices one's religion
to a hundred percent of its tenants it's
not worth practicing now I regard myself
as what I call a line drawing Jew I
don't practice all 613 tenants of the
law I draw the line and practice those
which I do but
in my book religion is about three
things
it's about a code of living
it's a framework by which we live
and it teaches self-restraint now that's
nothing to do with Judaism it applies to
all the main religions and
Professor Hawkins Dawkins would you not
have that talk to the children at an
early stage fine we'll take that
question on board and then there's a
question up there I believe yes
now I can't we can't hear you how about
now yes it's a question for Dr Spivey
um do you think the slaughtered millions
and hundreds killed every day in the
name of Faith are better off for the
existence of the Sistine Chapel and some
pretty paintings
right the first question about what are
we to tell the children Julia neuberger
well I don't know what you tell the
children in that I think that you were
really asking me to predict what they
will believe
I can only say this and it's something
that worries me I describe myself as
about as liberal as you can get without
falling off the edge and I rather resent
I must say Christopher Hitchens telling
me what a religious person has to
believe I think I'm the rabbi and he's
probably not but nevertheless
let me let me come to the point about
what
what I think will happen and I think
it's terribly worrying I think a lot of
our children will be people who hold no
very clear belief it will be a rather
woolly mush I would say if they have
much in the way of belief at all we've
we've desensitized them I think very
often to those things about religion
that I believe matter
what I think is extremely worrying is
seeing a rise of extreme religion so
that their children your grandchildren
May well be the ones who are sent sent
to Faith schools
May well be the ones who are given a
rather extreme and somewhat separatist
and intolerant view because I think
we're going into a cycle where that is
going to be more and more acceptable and
as somebody who believes that the
moderate should band together whether
religious or not I think we should be
very very worried about the move towards
extreme religious belief and the desire
to teach all our children in separate
boxes rather than together but I think
the generation of our children have got
a problem
Christopher will you take the question
about Christopher the question of I'm
sorry the question about the line
drawing Jew the practice of religion
being about the tone of living a
framework and about self-restraint well
that's dead easy just like the the rabbi
is now his religion is man-made too he
decides what he'd like to believe it's a
la carte he says shouldn't my children
be taught uh what was it self-restrained
responsibility occur for others and so
on I don't believe in the rest of it
don't believe in the prophets don't
believe in the Mountaintop do I believe
in the Revelation well nor should you
but how dare you suggest to us that we
couldn't teach our children
self-restraint respect for others in the
Golden Rule how dare you
foreign
I think the question put to you about
whether the slaughtered Millions were
worth the Sistine Chapel was something
of a rhetorical question but would you
would you have a comment to make
it uh yes it was slaughtered Millions
every day in the name of faith and um
uh that's quite a rhetorical
exaggeration of a thing and it's also
twisting what I was saying about the
Nexus of Art and religion
I would argue that the Sistine Chapel is
one of those things that shows Humanity
at its best and a religious conflict one
of the things that shows us at our worst
I don't buy this
idea that if we were all suddenly to
cease being religious
which I've tried to argue is I think
physically and psychologically
impossible that there would be a
complete absence of ethnic or any other
kind of conflict and that strikes me as
incredibly naive
thank you can I
another clutch impression we're not
going to get the hands are going up
everywhere I apologize now that we won't
get them all in but there's one over
there and one over there and one over
here but I'm looking for one up here is
there one up there yes okay there's
somebody over there so that's four can
you be quite quick please a question for
Professor scrutin if religion is
essentially the creation of meaning out
of brute matter then do you think it's
possible to make a religion of
secularism and if it is do you think
that the proposers of this motion are
its high priests
that okay Roger yes the question here I
disagree that we need religion to teach
us that we flowers are beautiful and
that without religion or with religion
we'd still kick over sand castles I
would therefore question whether anybody
could explain to me whether an actual
fact would be I think that we'd be much
the same without religion and I'd like
somebody to tell me other than that fine
okay I have a question up here
a brief would broadly support this
motion but I've got one little doubt
which was alluded to by the first
speaker and that is perhaps Were Somehow
hardwired for religion and I think
perhaps there's some evidence for a
genetic predisposition to a religious
belief and so on and therefore perhaps
it persists because of natural selection
and I just wanted to ask Professor
Dawkins whether that might be a good
argument for why it persists or um
whether it's perhaps a
an indirect consequence of something
else that we're better off with okay and
the fourth question yes
is this on oh that's better
um it's an observation and a question
the observation is there seemed to be
from the from this side seemed to be an
argument for Transcendence rather than
for religion
um perhaps the the uh anti-side of the
of the the anti-side might might uh
clarify that a little bit but the
question is to the panel uh which is
do they think that there may be given
the contingencies of history and culture
that created religion in the first place
there might be an opening of a space
that could give us all the great
kandinsky-like Transcendence without the
thousands of corpses could could that be
a possibility thank you okay Roger would
you take the question about
um the
particularism being its own religion and
these being its high priest well
this is um a slightly cheeky suggestion
if um what uh Dr Spivey says is right
and I'm inclined to agree with him then
of course there is a religious need in
all of us and if the religious belief
systems that we've inherited are um
suddenly for whatever reason
unpersuasive it is obviously true that
if that if what he says true people will
look for other ways of satisfying the
religious urge they will write
passionate books condemning the old
religious belief perhaps called The God
Delusion or something like that and
accuse The Advocates of uh of the false
Sciences of heresy and maybe indeed wish
to represent themselves as the saviors
of mankind and to that extent it is
obviously true that we do have a kind of
religious urge a much more vehement
religious urge on the other side of this
debate than on this this one and we are
Downstream from all those religious
conflicts I suspect us on the on this
table we we recognize with a certain
element of sadness our inability to go
out and kill on behalf of our faith
which um Professor Dawkins is obviously
not lost so maybe it is true
Bridget
I faced two questions firstly is
religion true and second is it necessary
for human psychological welfare or
something of that sort
if it isn't true
then for anybody to maintain that
somehow humans need it and you're
wasting your time trying to get rid of
it what an amazingly patronizing and
condescending thing to say
we intellectuals of course know that
it's not true but
[Applause]
all those poor people out there they
need religion I mean what a
condescending thing to say about about
all those people either it's true or
it's not and I have enough respect for
people to say that if it's not true
people will reconcile themselves to that
and will not find any need for it now I
was asked a specific question is that is
it in the genes is there some darwinian
reason for religiosity
maybe there is but that doesn't bear in
the slightest degree on whether it's
true
I care about whether it's true
I also care as a darwinian about the
origin of it and I'm interested in the
origin of it and I'm inclined to agree
with the um implied suggestion of the
questioner that it may be that religion
itself has no Advantage but it may be
that it's a byproduct of some other
psychological disposition which does but
that is an entirely separate question
from whether it's true
and I don't like it when people say oh
humans need it or we have it built into
us in our genes or darwinian natural
selection is built into it therefore
that somehow validates it of course it
doesn't validate it it merely says that
it's been built into us by natural
selection just as all sorts of other
probably disagreeable things have been
built into us doesn't mean we can't try
to cure ourselves
right okay can I just
[Music]
quickly
the point about Transcendence well I was
going to actually put that to Rogers
fruit and as it was addressed to that
particular side of the argument if we
could have Transcendence without
thousands of bodies and I'd like to
speak to that right but just very
briefly um the answer of course is is
yes I mean it's it's a wonderful fact
about human beings that they have this
yearning for the absolute that they they
sense the numinous that in moments of
great Passion infatuation deep love they
feel that they're in touch with
something which is richly important to
them in their experience those are facts
about human beings in order to explain
those facts you don't have to go to the
supermarket of ideas and take a deep
phrasing box out which says Islam or
Christianity or something you don't need
that explanation this is just a fact
about us and a very wonderful fact about
us and it may be that we can express
that all the more wonderfully if we
didn't try to parcel it up in in these
explanations which in so many other ways
irrational and Michael Yes Christopher a
sentence but um we don't want people to
live without Wonder or mystery and in
fact we thoroughly recommend take a look
through the Hubble telescope see if you
can get over what you see the
unbelievable Beauty and Symmetry and
Majesty of what you'll see and you want
to exchange this for the burning bush I
don't think you will once a time you
read a page of Stephen Hawking on the
Event Horizon for example let's see if
that isn't awe-inspiring enough for
anybody and you're seeing there the
future of a potentially much more noble
and innoble and enlightened and
emancipated Humanity where none of these
discoveries are none of this awe and
Majesty requires that you kill anyone in
the name of some man-made Idol or God or
Superstition For Heaven's Sake let's get
this out of the way Roger food
I I think that there is a real question
as to what Transcendence is
and what its place is in the experience
of all of us
the uh Christopher Hitchens just
referred to the burning bush the voice
that spoke from that bush said I am that
I am
it reminded us of this very peculiar
word which all of us use the word I
which doesn't identify any material
object in the world in which we are
situated but nor does it identify any
object out of that world
just what does it mean what is it to
look at somebody into somebody's eyes
and see the other eye that's looking out
at you that is an experience of
transcendence in itself it is the raw
material from which all religious faith
is constructed and it is part of the
metaphysical obscurity and
unintelligibility of our predicament
that we're all faced with this
experience every day and religion makes
sense of it for many people even for
those who don't have religion that
experience is still there
I have to move on quickly the final two
questions one up there and one here and
then we have to have the re-vote and a
summary from each of the speakers it's
going to have the questioner from upper
good evening
um question for Richard Dawkins uh
Professor sorry and Christopher Hitchens
by what measure do you conclude fact and
does Darwinism satisfy that measure in
other words
how do you protect yourself from
deception and how did Darwinism or
evolution
past that filter
fine can you take that on board
this question here yes I'm from the
national secular society and I'd like to
ask the opponents the motion whether
they think that life for women and
homosexuals would have been better or
worse without religion okay
a question about the measure and the
measure I wasn't quite sure
fact yes
the the measure of the fat the
factuality of uh evolution is the same
as in any other science
um some of the things that scientists
have found are found with great
confidence scientists are always open to
uh the possibility of being proved wrong
at some point in the future but there
are some things that seem at any one
stage in history far better demonstrated
than others the fact of evolution is
about as well demonstrated as anything
we know it is absolutely certain by the
normal standards the same kind of
standards as we are certain that
um the Earth rotates and and the sun
doesn't go around the earth that
formally we have to say well that's a
hypothesis that might one day be
disproved but we all know that it won't
be and evolution has now come into that
category I don't mean that Darwin's
theory of natural selection as at least
as the only driving force of evolution
that probably should be treated as
slightly more uncertain but the fact of
evolution Itself by which I mean the
fact that all living creatures that have
ever been looked at on this planet are
cousins sharing a common ancestor that
is uh a secure effect as as any in
science
and the question because I was named
please because I was asked by name I
feel very sensitive to second
Professor Dawkins in this area but I
would I would just remind you of what
Carl Sagan uh uh said on this
um which was he said that
there is no doubt that Evolution has
occurred it's it's in the molecular
biological record it's in the fossil
record there are disputes about how it
occurred the darwinian theory is only
the original one of how that might have
taken place and Darwin himself set out
as an original taxonomist in order to
prove the truth of Christianity
Justice Sir Isaac Newton believed in
alchemy and Joseph Priestly the
discoverer of oxygen believed in the
flogistian theory we are always ready
all of us on this side to be
self-critical to have a war within the
War uh which among scientists among
those who believe in Innovation evidence
hypotheses and their testing but that's
entirely different from anything that is
based on faith on the supernatural or on
Revelation all of which belongs to the
abject childhood of our species before
these things could even be discussed
there's no contrast between the two
magisteria if you like can I finally put
the last question to the the people who
oppose the motion which is would the lot
of women and homosexuals be better
without religion
Julia I think it depends where
um I think there are present extreme
forms of religion that persecute women
and certainly persecute homosexuals
I think when you look historically
at religions that we recognize and at
pre-religious times and Niger can talk
more about that you would see a
tremendous
um tremendous uh bad treatment of women
and I suspect that historically things
have got marginally uh better for women
and not a lot better for homosexuals
within the main religious Traditions I
have to say in the non-orthodox
religious Traditions across the faiths
the position of women and of homosexuals
has improved hugely but don't forget
that science also treated women and
treated homosexuals extremely badly
until the 1970s in my certain knowledge
gays were being treated with
electroconvulsive therapy as a form of
medical treatment I'm not sure what the
evidence was for that and don't forget
that the description of Hysteria as
something that particularly affected
women because of their wombs was also
apparently a scientifically I'm not
blaming scientists for that I'm just
saying that historically people have and
people have treated both women and
homosexuals and indeed black people and
all sorts of other minorities very badly
I think religion can give you insights
to treat people better and equally and
I'm not sure you can blame religion for
it all
I I can't I can't see the um particular
Quest you know but um if you'll pardon a
um as Judah said a historical reference
never in human history have gay men
enjoyed better rights than In classical
Athens in the fifth century before
Christ the only way that a woman could
get any position of power or respect in
that Society was uh to become a
priestess the gay men were given rights
essentially because they believed in An
Almighty God Zeus who was himself a gay
man
so one can bat these things back and
forward and I could say
you wouldn't have a Hippocratic Oath
without religion you wouldn't have
orphanages without religion there would
be children scrambling up the chimneys
of this Capital without religion but it
in a sense it's beside the point
it's beside the point
the point is that there are many men
have many manifestations of our
religious impulse some of them are
appalling and others of them are
thoroughly and nobling but we have them
all the same and no one on the other
side however many books they publish
however many documentaries they make is
going to get rid of it
thank you
we're running late and I know many of
you probably have dinner appointments
but I'm now going to ask for a summing
up from each of the people in turn I'm
going to ask them for two minutes
summing up of what they
um have thought throughout the evening
but but while they're doing that you
will be voting and you will have brought
into the Hall a card like this
please tear it in half and vote either
for or against the motion and if you
wish to abstain then don't tear it and
put the whole lot into the box people
will come round with the boxes and while
they are doing that we will hear from
each of these speakers in turn
okay if you're going to hear them you'll
have to uh
yeah well it's okay
okay
right before the Groundswell of
conversation gets too loud I'm going to
ask Christopher Hitchens to summarize
what his feelings are at the end of this
debate Christopher
I think I'll address myself principally
to talk to Spivey
who has dropped the motion not by uh
saying that religion should be
transcended
or would we would be better off if it
were to be but rather like Dr scrutinous
simply said well we can't hope to we're
stuck with it well that's not what the
motion says the motion says suppose we
could as some of us have transcended the
Supernatural and the superstitious would
our example if followed not be a
superior one I think we've made a pretty
strong case for that
um I'll correct him also on another
point a very common misapprehension and
I'll try and demonstrate in doing so
that we are not on this side death to
the numinous as it were it is flat out
not true to say the Karl Marx refer to
religion as an opiate or an opium what
he says I can quote it from memory from
his uh contribution to the critique of
hegel's philosophy of right is this
he says religion is the sigh of the
oppressed creature
the heart of the heartless world
the spirit of the spiritless situation
it is an opiate for the sufferer for the
people he goes on to say
the demand to give up its illusion is
the demand to give up the condition that
requires Illusions and he closes by
saying that criticism has plucked the
flowers from the chain not so that men
and women May wear the chain without
consolation but so that they may break
the chain and color the living flower
now that the fact that you've been lied
to about what he said All This Time by
religious spokesman shouldn't uh conceal
from you that we have a very clear
understanding of where this impulse
comes I actually don't like the Sistine
Chapel I didn't like it I didn't like it
even before I knew that every brick of
Saint Peter's was raised by the sale of
indulgences which obviously changes
nothing but not the scrutin either by a
special sale of indulgences by the way
but I do like the Parthenon very much
I've written a book about it and I think
I think of as as an achievement of
artistic symmetry
um and Architectural Glory it probably
has no Christian rival but I believe
that I can in fact I know I can I'm sure
I'm not the only one who has been there
and said and appreciated and loved it
without having to subscribe to these
superstitions of the ellucinian
Mysteries to The Cult of Athena and Zeus
to the million Expedition and the
Peloponnesian War to slavery and
Athenian imperialism and to Human
Sacrifice we can have our Parthenon
and we can indeed recover it from what
was done to it by Byzantine Ottomans by
Venetian Catholics by National Socialist
barbarians and many others we can still
have it it's our common property without
the superstitions that go with it
without the dread and fear and sacrifice
that the terrified cringing Humanity
that was so much sheltered uh under the
walls as it was being raised and the
word for that the ability to have these
things to have John Milton's poetry uh
to have Philip Larkin's perm Church
going to have uh Shakespeare without the
Superstition is called culture on which
we've all laid our lives on which we've
all sworn to defend ourselves and our
civilization against especially now
precisely against religious barbarism
against those who know they are right
against those who say they only need one
book against those who say they know
God's on their side against those who
say there's a revelation that's what
culture is that's what we're defend
ending yes we'll be better off with
culture and yes we can have it without
religion which is a mind forged manacle
thanks thank you
[Applause]
um at the risk of confusing any everyone
can I try and organize a straw vote I'm
in a hands in the air sort of vote and
can I ask you to be absolutely we're
waiting we're taking a vote right now I
know this is something different Joe
this is this is this is a question it's
not about it could have been about who
in this audience has ever shown violence
against their laptop but I'll use a Vic
constinian example hands up and don't be
bashful about this I'm going to start
off putting my own hand up who in this
room has ever
or can ever remember kissing a
photograph
likely less than I might have
anticipated but if you
if you've done that you have bet you
have behaved as in a sense Wittgenstein
is saying we'd all behave as ceremonious
animals we do things that don't have
reason behind them we do things for
performance we will go into I don't want
us to become all about Saint Peter's in
Rome but you know there's a bronze
statue there of some Peter and meant so
many people have touched the terms and
Peter that the toe has almost
disappeared
no okay we do silly things we die on
behalf of a friend and the things that
scientists can't explain that is my
scientific view which I restate my
personal View and it's voiced with the
Glam awareness that Methodist chapels
are currently closing at a rate of 100 a
year one lady said over there what are
our children going to believe what if
the motive that William James said was
the religious motive it's uneasiness so
all he says if when you feel uneasy
and you want to connect to some sort of
form of Hope When Things become
imponderable or incomprehensible you're
becoming uneasy you might do this by
imagining a higher power or expressing
yourself in this religious way what if
that uneasiness does indeed disappear
what if people no longer feel uneasy
about the fact that there might be more
to life than filling a trolley at
Tesco's
it's conceivable
and at that point I Surrender like
Samuel Beckett I sort of um hold my
hands up and say
you know I'll go and sit in an empty
church while everyone else is carousing
and just get miserable
um
but when the next robe spear or Stalin
or Himmler organizes us into a truly
irreligious society and sends me to
their version of Hell one that they've
created
I'm going to go there with the letters
of Dietrich Bonhoeffer in my pocket and
yes I'll be crooning some of those hymns
that nobody prunes anymore the hymns of
Charles Wesley
thank you thank you
although I can't recall ever having
kissed a photograph
I have
wept
when reading poetry when listening to
music
I think that those on this side have
come to rather resent the suggestion
that religion has a monopoly on emotion
on poetry
on sympathy on empathy
everybody in this room my dare say has
felt
deep grief
at the sight or the thought of a
suffering individual somewhere in the
world maybe even of another species
that does seem to be something in
humanity to feel empathy with suffering
and as a darwinian I can offer
explanations for that I won't do it now
because there isn't time
but it is a travesty that has somehow
become widely accepted that if you throw
out religion
you throw out
the Good Samaritan you throw out
Weeping at
a sonnet of Shakespeare
or at a Schubert quartet
it has nothing whatever to do with
religion in the sense of the
supernatural of course you can redefine
religion as covering all these emotional
artistic aspects and in that case of
course there's no contest but I suggest
that that's confusing and that we need
to Define religion as belief in
something Supernatural you get your
beliefs not from evidence but from Faith
from Revelation from tradition from
scripture from Authority now all those
are very bad reasons to believe anything
evidence is the only reason to believe
something
and that's the second point that I want
to make in closing but the first one the
main one I want to make is that uh We
Are All in This Together We Are all uh
capable of the same kinds of emotions
we're all capable of wanting to free the
slaves and all the things all the good
things that have been talked about
whether we're religious or not uh you
cannot give religion the credit for any
of those things they are a part of
humanity the good things of part of
humanity just as the bad things about it
Humanity whether you're religious or not
foreign
[Applause]
well I think I'm sure
in fact I'm sure I'm sure I've never
known Lucas to photograph
I can't imagine why I would
I'd rather kiss the real person I think
at least if it was somebody I wanted to
kiss
um I'm left thinking
that we have a confusion here
we're having a definition
of religion
which seems to me to be
not like a definition I recognize
as somebody who comes from the moderate
wing of religion
seems to me that the voices of the
prophets
may help you to do the right thing and
I'm not for one single moment suggesting
that people who aren't religious don't
do the right thing
but when we hear something like Isaiah
saying
not interested in the forms of religion
but actually in the moral truth
that stirs me and it stirs many other
people your countless sacrifices what
are they to me the offer of your gifts
is useless it's new moons and sabbaths I
can't endure
but when you get ceased to do evil and
learn to do right pursue Justice and
Champion the oppressed give the orphan
his rights and plead the Widow's cause
it's not the ritual that matters but the
moral cause it strengthens my resolve it
strengthens lots of people's resolve it
sensitizes you to issues of Justice
and for many of us religious but not
Fundamentalist there is a voice of God
that we can hear within us and yes I
suppose in Richard Dawkins terms that is
a supernatural it may be our consciences
a prick of shame or guilt at what we've
done or perhaps even worse what we
haven't done and we live our lives aware
that we're being judged by ourselves
first and foremost but also by something
above and beyond us before whom we
always fall short now we can believe
that without certainty and we can Wonder
at creation along with Richard Dawkins
believing in Evolution 2 you don't have
to be an extremist to be religious but
without religion our world is the poorer
foreign
I think it's perfectly clear from from
the the conversation that we've had
among us this evening that uh to do good
to be good to want the good to want it
to prevail
you don't have to be anything you don't
have to be a subscriber to Hinduism or
the Olympian gods or the Norse gods or
or anything in in fact on the contrary
if you look back across the landscape of
history and you see how Humanity has
been loaded with suffering and uh
Division and conflict as a result of
religious differences you look back you
see that early Christians of different
sects who loathe one another so much
that when they were thrown to the Lions
they used to run to opposite ends of the
of the um things so they wouldn't be
eaten by the same lions and you you look
at what's happening in Baghdad today you
think of the way history
screams at us with gory throats about
the the atrocities that have been
committed in the name of faith and you
ask yourself isn't it the case that
these very natural very warm feelings
that human beings can have for one
another when they know one another
individually that it becomes impossible
to generalize and if you know somebody
from another Nation or another culture
another ethnicity you know somebody well
personally it's very very hard to
continue to generalize to accept the
sorts of Divisions that people want to
impose because of labels because of the
identities that they choose for
themselves
and you see that the that the deepest
division that has existed between people
in human history recorded human history
is the set of religious differences
which has been productive of so much
conflict and suffering you think of that
and you move to the individual sphere
you think of the of the teenager who is
anxious because his private feelings may
be leading him into sin or he's done
something that may damn his Immortal
Soul because he's been told that it will
you think about the torment of that so
on every scale you can think of ways in
which religion religious belief
religious hegemony religious oppression
has stood in the path of the good
and we know from there from the
historical record how organized
religious bodies have resisted truth and
nail every inch of progress that's been
made in science
look at the history of the modern West
for example since the Reformation
their desire to increase the liberty of
the individual against the desire of of
religion supporting absolute monarchy to
keep control over individuals the idea
of the secret policeman who sees what
you do in the dark it's a wonderful
instrument of control over people's
minds and what what has been sought in
in the period of of uh time that has
elapsed since the Reformation has been
an increasing margin of discretion for
individuals that make their own choices
make up their own mind and to live a
life which is free of those Tremors
which their imagination and their will
is not loaded down with ancient stories
that come from the the infancy of
humankind
would we be better off with that
religion so so much better off if only
we could breathe the free air of our of
our personal Liberty our choice our
freedom to love one another as human
beings and cooperate with one another
not because of labels not because we
don't want to go to hell but because we
choose to
and finally Roger
I think that um there's a
misunderstanding on the side part of
those who've been proposing the motion
as to what we on our side have actually
been saying I don't think anybody here
has wished to deny
the atrocities committed in the name of
Faith though if we are to produce this
argument to that kind of head counting
we ought at least to acknowledge the
atrocities committed in the name of
Atheism in the last century especially
Mount Si Tung
Stalin Lenin Hitler and a few others are
pretty impressive on this in this regard
but these are very vulgar and
unimportant Arguments for us we know
that nobody in this room is remotely
tempted in that direction the real
question is what
religion can do in the lives of people
like us is it something that can benefit
us or is it something that will harm us
now I think Professor Dawkins is
absolutely right to say that religion
does not produce the moral and aesthetic
emotions that so many of us value it is
not at least the only product producer
of those things they rely deep in human
nature perhaps alongside the religious
urge but separable from it the question
is having been separated do they have
the same chance of survival now my view
is that this question is not about the
truth of any particular religion oh and
and I don't think that the question the
truth of religion is a scientific
question anyway it's a question as
Thomas Aquinas recognized of the
ultimate dependence of existence of
being on some some ground or some final
explanation but I don't think the
question is about truth the question is
about whether our religious feelings
which we undeniably exist can be focused
rightly or wrongly and if they're
focused rightly whether they produce the
kind of Redemptive effect in our
experience that religious people claim
and I would say that if focused were
like rightly on the uh the creator of
the universe who created it out of all
embracing love then they will always
reflect well in our individual lives
thank you Roger
before I announce the result I would
just like to say that each of these
distinguished speakers is prepared to
sign books that they have written which
are out there what a captive moment just
as you want the result but you should
know that
um also I would before you all Rush the
off the moment I've given the results
say
how grateful we all are for hearing this
debate tonight
thank you
it's been effective in making up a lot
of Mind there are only a hundred don't
knows and the vote now for the
resolution that we'd be better off
without religion is
1205 and against that's also gone up
778 so the motion is Carrie thank you